يبلغ طول
هذه الجزيرة الهادئة 820 قدمًا وعرضها 200 قدمًا ، وكانت ذات يوم
موقعًا مركزيًا وتوقفت بسبب
صناعة قطع الأشجار المزدهرة
[الموسيقى] حيث
تقع على بعد حوالي ميل واحد خارج
مدينة روفانيمي ، تعد عاصمة
لابلاند واحدة من أصغر جزر فنلندا وهي
جزيرة أوريزاري الخلابة
محاط بنهر كيمي حسنًا ،
كان النهر يستخدم مرة واحدة كقناة عائمة من
قبل صناعة الأخشاب حتى عام 1980 ،
وبعد ذلك تم استبدال ممارسة تحريك جذوع الأشجار
على المياه بالشاحنات بينما لا
يعيش أحد في الجزيرة ، يمكن الوصول إليها من
قبل الزوار عن طريق القوارب من  من مايو إلى أكتوبر
مع ما يقرب من 500 ضيف يقومون
برحلة لزيارتها سنويًا حتى يومنا هذا ،
لا تزال الجزيرة تبحث كما كانت في
أوج عطائها ، والتلميح الوحيد للعصر الحديث
هو منزل الطيور القديم الذي تم
تجديده وتحويله إلى حانة
للزوار  لتناول وجبة واستكشاف
محطة استراحة الحطاب
[موسيقى]